as democrats
what are we fighting for for the workers
for the dreamers and asylum seekers
for those with disabilities for seniors
for safer schools neighborhoods and
communities
for secure retirement for opportunity
for our country we
are the party of the people we
are democrats
there you go everybody you saw it right
there loud and clear
hey everybody welcome good afternoon
this is the wayne de breeze show i am
not waiting to pray
it's day four he's still out he's still
on vacation he will be back next week
we have the spirit of wayne hovering
over us as we speak now
my name is brian smith i'm a co-host
along with the beautiful lea bella
hello yeah he better have a margarita
and some lobster or something he better
be doing something fun today
shout out to facebook youtube cloud hub
rt
who am i forgetting youtube i think i've
named everybody periscope
parlor partly yeah make sure you're
sharing the show
because you might have somebody on the
fence you share the show
they watch us and go what was i thinking
i gotta vote
i gotta vote for trump right yes
absolutely and you guys i know
most of you probably all of you didn't
do anything last night
in regards to watching the dnc i did it
for you
i did do it for you i watched the entire
thing you did too
yeah oh barack hussein obama
18 eye bleeding minutes
and uh no i don't want that scam call
oh my isn't that awesome how how iphones
tell you it's a scam call coming in
sorry phone oh yeah yeah i actually that
is kind of it's convenient
hello melinda from arkansas i just want
to give a shout out to a couple people
saying hi
everywhere uh let's see who else do we
have here we've got maria
i think she's over in uh scotland or
ireland
hi maria bug dispenser says hey guys
so hello everybody belfast that's it
maria spencer i'm dispenser really she's
from
maine maine she says she loves us so oh
fantastic
okay great awesome uh oh
i guess i can't see the cat oh yeah
we have uh see i'm not good with names
how do you say that name oh i know how
taylor
oh she just got a spam call too oh
that's funny is the linda i think or
the media from pensacola florida she
says hi
bunny from michigan i like named bunny
nurse navigator
yeah nurse navigator from texas you
might want to stay on uh
i got my my indispensable hcq shirt on
today
yeah i got got a couple of updates so we
talked we uh we stayed up late we
watched the
barack obama hillary clinton uh benghazi
duo
uh their uh trifecta their partner in
crime
uh john mccain has since passed on but
uh pelosi
she gave a speech as well and we'll be
talking about that i got a couple of
a couple of videos for you and um
we got a special guest at the bottom of
the hour special guest
uh good friend of mine you absolutely
love him he is running for congress
so you want to want to definitely make
sure if you are in his district or you
know somebody definitely tell them
our president um is absolutely backing a
lot of
speaking about that i forgot to say this
tuesday tuesday was a huge day for
america and i forgot to say it
there are a lot of mega candidates
that overtook the rhino republicans in
tuesday's election
good for yeah for the primaries our good
friend of the show
laura loomer down there in florida she
did
so apparently the debacle with that she
tweeted out or other people tweeted out
that the
the news media 48 hours ahead of time
said she
had zero percent chance of winning and
but who believes the news mainstream
media anyways
apparently it's something they do
before the election yeah it's called lie
right keep you to stay home but anyway
she won with a very healthy 42 percent
of the
42 plus percent of the vote so she did
really really good donald trump giving
her a shout out
as she goes up against a democrat your
thoughts on her winning
congress say she wins yeah how does
social media
deal with a person of congress that has
been permanently
suspended across the nation i thought
about this and
the only thing that i can think that
she's going to be able to do
is have it laura loomer congress like
she's going to have to have someone
represent her to get her word out there
does that make sense so she'll have an
account but it won't be her personal
account
it'll be like you know how people
represent donald trump
the people of donald trump it'll be the
people for laura loomer she'll have to
go through a third party
which is so sad that we're getting to
that point in
in uh 1980 country yeah yeah
we're literally all gonna have to go
through third party just to get
anything out all right right no i'm with
you it's
uh i got a message from a friend saying
that uh another conservative has been
permanently banned from facebook
people getting taken down it's just it's
worrisome you have to really watch what
you say and
it that's not that's not how it should
be
no no absolutely not i agree uh
we are going to be talking a little bit
about joe biden some of his uh
ideologies some of his uh things that he
is doing
uh juxtapose what donald trump is doing
uh
then we'll wrap up again again our guest
at the bottom of the hour and then we'll
wrap up with some of the videos of covid
that we didn't get to for last week
okay pick it pick one pick one let's
talk about obama's speech
okay wow wow
his was the longest i believe wasn't it
like 18 minutes or
50 everything everything he does feels
like eternity
so yeah this is what i can say
when donald trump makes a speech he
makes me proud to be an american
so i asked myself last night after
obama's speech
did he make me feel like a proud
american
and i get it that he had to bash trump
and build up his friend
his buddy joe right right but you know
what
rock i get it that a chinese virus came
over here
i get it that there are pre-meditated
and pre-funded riots going on to cause
chaos
but you can't break me bro i'm so proud
i'm still proud to be an american
and you can stand up there and you can
tell me how
my president is unfit for office while
you committed treason
and you spied on him you're not fit for
america
and you're what yeah yeah and your wife
can tell me
that if donald trump gets back in office
that it is going to get worse well guess
what
i'm no longer being gaslighted by you
and your wife i can now recognize the
red flag signs
of brainwashing that you guys did to us
for eight years and that makes me
be a proud american that i can see that
now that i don't have to listen to that
and when i hear hillary speech last
night and she's still bitter
about losing the election that makes me
a proud american but you know what makes
me even more proud
the fact that donald trump's speech is
about bringing peace
back to the middle east that makes me a
proud american
what didn't make me a proud american was
that speech last night
because he's not proud of america so he
can take himself he can take his wife
and he can pack himself into unmarked
pallets and ship himself to iraq
because that's where he deserves to be
and that's how i feel about that
it's exactly where he deserves to go
that's how i feel about that
it was uh dial it all the way back go
all the way back to 08 and again
uh you know wayne makes a good point
that
obama did have an opportunity to be a
president that would be remembered for
the good forever when he was handed
an incredibly awful economy uh
we saw the housing market crash we saw
everything fall apart and
what was his words his words were uh
you know some of those jobs sorry man so
his job just ain't coming back
some of those jobs that you you wish you
had you thought you had they're just not
coming back anymore
and then it continued crush the coal
industry all
all the uh all the scandals starting off
with fast and furious
and the border patrol agent brian that
was killed i just
it's unconscionable that he continues to
go on and on about this
all right thanks wayne i agree melinda
says you go girl tammy says you're a
spitfire uh
yeah thank you guys no i appreciate it i
just it makes me angry to see
someone uh hate our country so much
right real quick i uh i just got
cattle prodded uh breaking news okay
breaking news um i've been steve bannon
and joined teams with brian koffledge
the one
that was the triple amputee uh veteran
combat veteran that was gofundme for 25
million dollars of the wall
remember that sorry to shift gears on
you guys breaking news i will get back
to obama
yeah not probably always give back to
obama there's always terrible things to
say
steve bannon and brian kofledge have
been arrested
oh look at that yes on charges of uh uh
conspiring to
uh move money around illegally
uh brian had put up and there's a video
over on the daily caller the daily
caller lists
brian's uh tweets on his timeline
it's still live it's still on twitter
and a video brian's saying i
promise you i will not take one penny
100 of all the money you donate now goes
to the wall
i will not take a dime when then he took
a dime
and then he took another dime then he
took a couple more dimes
yeah apparently a million and a half
oops excuse me went to
uh steve bannon steve bannon set up a
non-profit organization
to donate the money to and about 300
some odd thousand dollars came back
around to brian kofflidge
this is what the uh this attorney is
saying this is not me this is what
they're saying that they're alleging
uh and it's until proven guilty uh
but the money came back around to brian
to fund his lavish lifestyle
steve bannon uh apparently uh kited
about a million dollars for himself and
um
lawsuit filed by people who donated
to the fund me went to dc or
sorry i went to new york and filed the
documents to have them
both of them arrested uh and so now
and we're talking about that wall that
we brought up a couple of weeks ago
right which trump didn't agree with
anyways
right correct correct trump said i never
ever authorized this i thought it was a
bad idea to build this wall
in this place because it's a bad place
for the wall
and now local authorities and inspectors
are what not
saying that the wall is crumbling and
issues with the footing
and the ground water lots of problems
and so
out of the 25 million he raised they
spent 2
million on the wall
that's sick i'm glad they were arrested
though
at least that's happened we've got to
see more arrests whether it's this case
or
any other case like it there has to be
arrests so
good right and um
again donald trump disagreed with the
entire thing
um yeah i remember he was he was venomly
you know he was angry about that right
and people are
taking to social media screaming and
yelling brian's a triple empty
vietnam veteran not being i'm sorry he's
a veteran he's a member
that's what everybody says if somebody's
homeless i've been not a veteran
at home cut that out i'm a veteran
and i know personally a veteran
that has a lot of problems right now
he's
i know him very very well and the va
is is continuing to support
his horrible habits of alcoholism
and and keeping him broke but keeping
him home
in an apartment and they're paying for
everything the program's awful because
he's staying an alcoholic and he's
staying in an apartment and it's all
being
covered for by the va and he doesn't
have to work wow
so i know veterans that aren't yeah you
know they've got some issues and i know
the va's
got its broken issues so don't come at
me and say brian he's a veteran
well no i mean you can't do illegal
things and justify it with that
not a story right okay shifting back
uh do you want us
scandals galore with barack obama his
speech
all about race black
white race racist racism america's
racism
uh going all the way back to he
mentioned jim crow laws and all that
hold on man that's you at the democrat
party
yeah he didn't make you feel proud to be
american in fact he made you feel guilty
about your past you're present
and if you don't vote joe you made you
feel guilty about your future
right all right god bless you barack
hussein obama
god bless you uh nothing was brought up
about the writers the protesting the
burning of portland the burning of
uh wisconsin whatever's going on there
still or new york
no nothing of course because they can't
pin it on trump it's not trump's fault
they know what's happening in their
liberal cities and again these were
premeditated riots they're prepaid poor
riots so they already knew about them
this is what their plan is they want it
to be like this everything the democrats
do are premeditated
that's just be truthful about it oh no
we got a special guest trying to come up
with muscle guys
he's trying to break off hold who could
this be
he said he had a better connection with
his phone
oh no man there he is
what's going on look at this
who's this styling and profiling by the
lake
what's going on wayne i um
i was watching what y'all were saying
about coppad's thing just a few minutes
ago
yeah ladies and gentlemen oh he's got a
tan thank you bear boy i appreciate that
[Music]
i just i just want to let i just want to
uh second everything brian was talking
about and i want to let all of y'all
know out there
that uh sometimes it's hard to call out
people that are on our side it is it's
hard
and it seems like many conservatives
don't want to call out brian because
they say that he is uh
like brian said you know a triple
amputee and they
can't see him doing something wrong like
this
people people were complaining about
brian a long time ago and
people didn't want to accept it um
that there was a legitimate
401 no non-profit
organization that had a plan for the
building a wall they they did and when
they contacted brian
yeah well um brian kovacs when they
contacted brian
ryan anyone had nothing to do with him i
know the guy personally
and he was helping me with a non-profit
and we talked about the entire thing
so you're absolutely dead on wayne they
did right and they didn't want to have
anything to do
with the real thing um
when they start raising money now see
here's my problem
and i know a lot of people are defending
bannon and to a point i am too
however when you start reading when you
start
that stuff is damning man that i mean
i know how y'all are saying well no it's
a setup
sd how can it be a setup when they use
your own words
not only you use your own words but also
uh detail how and we talked about this
earlier this morning wayne
when he raised that 25 million dollars
he didn't have nowhere to go with it he
didn't
he did it gofundme was threatening to
keep the money
yep yep he did i mean you know he said
well
when we get all the money then we have a
connection over at dhs nope
not true it didn't work like that so
what brian did brian decided to put
put lipstick on a pig and hire bannon
and hire some other people
to give it a legitimate look
well hey i mean if you bring on sheriff
clark and you bring on brian bannon and
you bring on these people
we gonna continue sending you money well
that look bottom line is
leah leah just brought the pain and said
president trump last month say look i i
didn't ask him to do this
i'm not a part of it and they're trying
to embarrass me
that's what president trump said okay so
um if either you are a trump supporter
and you follow what trump said or you're
going to defend brian
and steve based i mean and
and and say okay well maybe president
trump should have backed him
no president trump is smart he's not
dumb
he's been doing this he's a builder he's
been doing this his entire life
he can smell a rat when he you know when
they're there he can see that mile away
yep yep so yeah yo
we'll be back can y'all see this
beautiful place yeah it's gorgeous
really nice
wow oh boy
man we're gonna have a party there you
can hear the wind chimes
yeah that's your last thing that
went oh seagull what's in on the show
yeah that'd be great if it just landed
near you no it ain't
[Laughter]
no but um we we're gonna be on our way
back
uh tomorrow morning so uh bearboy says
have a few beers on us
let me tell you something we didn't have
internet
for the first couple days
comcast cut the main internet line this
morning
so we didn't have anything this morning
and then they just came in and fixed it
so
whatever uh brian and leah have been
doing a great job i've been watching
them
and i want to thank everybody out there
that it has been
sharing what they have done all week
long y'all have given them some of the
um the best numbers
non wayne included y'all have y'all have
really
pushed them uh and and really shared
great shared what they've been talking
about in great numbers and
let me ask you a question can i pick a
team or can i can
i'm going to take more vacation now
but well i got to go i'm going gonna
keep on watching y'all and um
y'all keep on doing what you're doing
y'all got a guest coming in and
um yeah uh you know just keep your heads
up and keep
i mean look y'all got this y'all got
this
and um i'll see y'all tomorrow no
actually i'm going to be watching
wait wait i'm going to be watching y'all
tomorrow on um
[Music]
yeah so let everybody know that the
wayne the pre-show
the pre-show is going to be on since tv
every friday yes
so um y'all tune into that and thank you
for all the patreons too
uh uh we're we're at 117.
now nice wow
so don't forget to um do that and brian
love you man leah love you too
my brother oh yeah the beautiful
liabella
wait wait on there look we're down here
she don't like being
very relaxing i got to hear the beach
wind and see the water so i kind of feel
rejuvenated
especially after that obama speech i
kind of needed that i know i was a
little pressed uh
myself so i forgot i didn't know if you
knew he was coming on
who why dwayne yeah no i didn't know a
couple people weren't coming on but
we'll talk about that later i'm joking
i tried i'm just i'm just flying by the
seat of my pants folks hey hey
you're doing great you're doing great so
that's all we can do
yeah we got our guests coming on here in
about five five to seven minutes so i'll
tell you what
uh we'll just preface hillary clinton
with
a short clip of her last night and then
we talk about that on the backside okay
the morning after the last election i
said
we owe donald trump an open mind and the
chance to lead
i meant it every president deserves that
and trump came in with so much set up
for him
a strong economy plans for managing
crises including a pandemic
yes we democrats would have disagreed
with him on many things
but if he had put his own interests and
ego aside
seeing the humanity in a child ripped
from her parents at the border
or a protester calling for justice or a
family wiped out by natural disaster
that would have been a good thing for
america and the world
i wish donald trump knew how to be a
president
because america needs a president
right now
wow okay i got a question for you i've
listened to this
a couple of times and she says and i
can't rap like
i can't understand what she's talking
about she says when a woman
has her child ripped away from her at
the border
or a family wiped out by a natural
disaster
that's a good thing for the world yeah i
don't understand either
i was trying to piece that together and
i don't know
if she was trying to say this is a
that's a good thing for the world
to see because he's not handling it
right i didn't get it either i don't
know if she glitched
or i forgot about her glitch yeah i'm
not sure exactly what happened there
but what i got from that speech was
bitter
oh still bitter yes she's you know she
didn't even congratulate
um kamala
i don't think she did did she did you
hear it now that you mentioned it i did
not know
because she's super jealous she wanted
to be that woman
and now this kamala comes in i'll tell
you kamala's on her bad side already
komala better watch because
she does not like her and i could tell
because she did not say a word about her
don't you think as a democrat party
leader you would have been really
propping her up and been excited
she said nothing i'm trying to think
about that
wow it was a very very bitter speech
what was telling was the very first
couple of sentences
we set donald trump up for success
and literally that's what she said she
should have just she should have stopped
that we set donald trump up
right and vote cut point blank that's it
and when she said the morning after
i said we got to give him a chance you
might have said that but what you were
thinking was totally different
you were already trying to think how you
can pr push this russian narrative
could get him out of office
we know how you think hillary you're not
fooling anybody
no no nobody at all not so whatsoever
you're unlikable
you're more unlikable now the entire
night
was about sex uh lgbtq
uh women men it was
genders it was people it was all idea
uh idea biologics what is
politics well yeah the thing is it's uh
radical environment policies
it's let me think here eliminating
private health
coverage uh glorified late term
abortions america
yeah there's nothing new orders abolish
i
defund the police what else was in there
there's absolutely um benefit for
illegal aliens i mean this is what i
want
there's zero zero ideas
that are new it is all old rehash
and my take away from all the speeches
although
pelosi's was just as pathetic as the
rest of them uh
she was straight robotic monotone i just
in fact there was a lot of hatred in
that too
and i just like i said i wanted to go
into this with an open mind
and say okay what can i bring to our
audience
about this dnc right and it
did not make me feel proud to be an
american they
were shaming everyone and when you hear
donald trump's speech
he makes you be proud to be an american
they do not
they bring out this hatred and this
shame that they want you to have
so that way you feel like you have to
riot for what you want
where trump does the opposite he makes
you feel proud he makes you want to
stand for the national anthem he makes
you want to stand up for the flag
they don't want you to do that they want
you to feel shamed they want you to feel
worthless
and that's what their message was last
night
it was shaming to its finest and
i wasn't gonna i wasn't standing for it
god bless america
and like i keep saying and i kept saying
all last night
keep on going pelosi keep on going obama
because you're not
gonna knock us down you're not gonna
break us
you're not gonna break us we're proud to
be americans you're not gonna break us
and they hate that it's like to pay i
wish i had that picture of that video of
the
who's in whoville without the christmas
tree
just continuing to sing as if the
christmas tree was really there
you know yeah i mean that's what it is
guys
my big takeaway is that they're all
about
themselves they're all about their power
it's not they didn't highlight joe biden
you realize that
they did not highlight joe biden last
night
no they just started talking about all
the identity that's the word i was
looking for identity identity politics
uh it was all racist sex is big and
homophobe
uh donald trump killed 170 uh yeah i was
going to say it was all about his
running mate coveted 19.
that's you got to remember to say that
every single show because that's what it
is
i didn't hear them highlighting camila
harris at all they
highlighted kovid 19 they highlighted
all the deaths just like um it was cuomo
the other day
so despicable how cuomo did what he did
he called it the european virus
let's get it straight it came from china
my and then it went to europe right
not a european virus but como doesn't
care because he's writing a book on it
and he needs to make the money
he needs to make some money right right
yeah so
so as i promised at the bottom of the
hour we've got our special guest
coming on uh his good friend i've worked
with him before american priorities
conference i
when i first got the meeting back in
just a phenomenal guy a lot going on on
this plate and now he's running for
office uh let me introduce our good
friend
john paul what's going on john ryan how
are you doing how's it going hey liam
hi how are you man so
it's been a while since we've gotten
together but man it's good to see you
again
um so now i see you on social media and
you're running for office
i'm running for united states congress
here in massachusetts in the most
winnable state
the state you've seen in decades it's
it's very very it's a very competitive
seat against
get this seth moulton
for president for a hot minute take out
nancy pelosi and
he's yeah it's seth moulton that's right
the uh
yeah so we have a lot to do but he's
it's we haven't had a republican
in congress or massachusetts in a
quarter century
wow that was going to be my question
what's going on with republicans in
massachusetts
well a lot's going on this year we have
we have we have a few people running for
congress
uh as republicans and effectively
it you know since the jfk era which i
argue jfk would clearly be a republican
today
oh yeah that's the funny thing about all
that they they built this
one party state because of jfk legacy
and he would have nothing to do with
his uh red-headed stepchild haiku joe
kennedy
the third total [ __ ] you know open
borders
extreme lefty all the way be murder
babies up in silver the whole thing
um and but but he'd have nothing to do
with those people and that that's that's
kind of a funny angle right there but
um yeah it's the most politically
intolerant state in the country but
we're breaking a lot of ground i
personally meet people all my district
and i'd say i'd say even the majority of
democrats
are saying they would support me over
moulton after i talk with them
fantastic so how yeah i was gonna my
next question how's your ground game
uh what are you seeing out there talking
with the people
it's uh well you know massachusetts is
ready for this about
my state my district as well about 11
percent
republican 32 percent democrat about 55
percent independent
so what it is people are so afraid to be
republicans that they're
they're republican but they registered
as independent because they don't
anybody know the republicans
um but i'm getting i'm getting a vast i
mean
every republican of course nine out of
ten independents and i'd say almost 50
percent of democrats that i talked to
say they can't send seth holden he's not
in the district he doesn't show up he
doesn't do his job wow
he votes with nancy pelosi 100 of the
time 100 not 95. not not easily
100 of the time and all he talks about
is
president trump is the reason for
everything and um
and you know and republicans are all
evil and
i don't know if he is oh and we're all
racist
so he's suffering from trump derangement
syndrome then
oh extreme i mean every single thing you
see
is uh trump arrangement syndrome and
you're a racist he called police races
from milwaukee to marblehead and he just
is on it he's just crazy that's all they
have because they see trump's numbers
uh pre-covered like i was saying joe
biden's running mate
is covered 19. it's not come out camilla
it's it's covered 19.
so what are the democrats that you're
talking about exactly so the democrats
that you're talking to what how do they
feel about joe are you seeing a lot of
joe biden signs up there in
massachusetts what's going on
i've seen like maybe two i mean i've
seen hi
and um my signs are out there much more
than seth moulton's as well
um even though we have a smaller budget
and we're real grassroots
we're getting people we're getting store
owners i'm very big on small business so
i'm getting a lot of support from
businesses they're putting my sign up as
large as they can
we're getting more and more big signs
made saving a lot of money on billboards
because
small businesses are saying this guy
actually supports us seth moulton
would just assume everybody shut down
and be dependent on government but
people are not
um we don't see i mean i don't see
anybody running to joe biden's defense
it really is the bot
the democrats are hiding in the basement
don't talk about
com communist commonly don't thomas
don't talk about creepy
um you know mentally deranged uh joe
they just hope that they're gonna get
people to hate trump enough that they
vote for joe as the alternative that's
what they're
it's all smoke and mirrors just vote
against trump
and you're going to end up with this
horrible
horrible administration that will by the
way they're going to stuff the supreme
court they're going to they're going to
add two people to the supreme court we
know who they are
and america is done i mean we'll never
see another republican president
not going to see a majority in congress
anymore after this either
if they get their way i agree with you a
hundred percent i said did you watch any
of that
that [ __ ] show last night by chance i
was gonna ask the same thing if you
watched any
i try to but i really get i'm afraid i'm
i don't want to get the dumb disease so
the more i watch it i'm just
i'm afraid of getting as stupid as those
dopes and so i try to watch it a little
bit
but it's like drunk it's a bad drug if
you watch it too much
you just your iq lowers um but i did
watch some of it it's just
it is just unbelievable this is the
thing i tell people their whole thing
is racism and bigotry right i'm a gay
man they're the bigots
and they're the homophobes because they
tell me that i have no brain of my own i
have to listen to them i have to vote
for them
and they know all they're progressive
supremacists
and a liberal racist they are they're
they're the ones that are
the racists and pigots it's so crazy
that people don't see it everybody
should see that they're the racists and
bigots all the way back to the
civil war they've been that way and you
see as donald trump
could could really care less whether
you're black you're white you're gay
you're straight look what he did with
uh richard gernell i i mean witness
i mean didn't uh martin luther king say
by not by the color of my skin but the
concept of my character and donald trump
picks it picks richard to to do what
they should be doing in this
administration he did a phenomenal job
exposing all the criminalities from the
democrat party
yeah good so i'm just gonna say and i
think it's shocking that they're not
bringing up anything about the riots
that are happening as well which is what
the peaceful riots seth moulton calls it
a march for
freedom that's what i was going to ask
you when he calls
how much freedom is that when you're
when you built a business up over 30
years and it gets looted and burned and
burned to the ground you lose everything
where's the freedom in that i'm just
wondering where that freedom is that
kind of
maybe you're free from your business
because it's all burned down you're like
yes
no more business no more i'm free from
making money
he said he's calling it a march for
freedom
and maura healey our attorney general
massachusetts
said when they burned down all the
beautiful businesses in downtown boston
during the riots she said you know you
don't grow
up you you grow a new forest you have to
burn down some trees
um you know the burned down trees that
that you know we rightfully deserve
because you know people that work hard
and build a business don't have any
right to that business
you have a right to get it burned down
so that's what massachusetts to say to
men
all the liberal lefties here think that
um it's all about burning a forest
you know burning the trees so you can
build a new forest wow that
doesn't even make sense well well we're
talking about
radical smoking better would not be
happy because he says only you can
prevent forest fires oh yeah smoking
smoking no i think smokey must be a
racist
yeah well there you go he is the biggest
racist that smokey the marriage he tells
you so your platform would you say that
your platform pretty much aligns with
uh your run-of-the-mill conservatives
met with some of the things that you um
that hit home to you what are some of
the things that hit home to you
so uh my my um philosophy is uh i
i kind of started i i ran an
organization about grant opportunity usa
inspired by the idea let's call the
grant opportunity party the ground
opportunity
parties the grand old party because we
are we are conservatives are
all about opportunity not just economic
personal opportunity because of our
liberties economic opportunity
educational opportunity the left wants
what no opportunity education they want
to tell you where you're going to go to
school right
right national opportunity your security
they don't want you to be able to
sleep sleep at night because you know
they did democrats where was it the uh
was it was it in milwaukee they said
they said uh
the democrats said well somebody said
well what about if you're you're home at
night and you're being robbed and
someone's breaking into your house
and they said that's privilege that's
critical you shouldn't
you shouldn't be thinking of a as a
privileged person
you have stuff that people need so you
should probably just let them rob you
i think it was a city council member
that said that yeah it was
so we're dealing with these people that
are literally insane and my view is
unity liberty and opportunity for all um
keeping america great and and focusing
on opera the principles of opportunity
which is why people come to america in
the first place the old land of
opportunity right
the left is uh power wealth and control
and i have a new logo i have a new i
have a new message for i'm going to give
this to the democrats for free ready
loot america 2020
america 2020. they want to do to you and
the country what they're doing in
portland in seattle and everywhere else
they go and they see success they hate
it they're angry
they burn it down and they beat you and
they rob from you
and that's the democrat party of today
so all right you know
loot america 2020. i'm going to give it
to them they can have it
they deserve it in the video that i
played at the very beginning to start to
show off
was somebody in the back of voiceover in
the background uh
talking about the democrat ideologies
and policies and where we're headed as a
democrat but the video in the background
was all the writing and all the looting
and and that's exactly what it was last
night it was
they they claim that donald trump was
and doing everything that he's doing is
what they're doing
yeah and that they're doing or they're
gonna do
everything donald trump did starting
2016. i don't know if you heard it
but hillary clinton said when she
started her speech out she said
we set donald trump up to to succeed we
wanted to see the best in him we gave
him a great economy we did this and this
and
peaceful transfer like holy hell
what's your thoughts on that no it's
completely bizarre and
i think that it's simply this that
they've they've spent decades they wrote
a book about this called accused
conservatives the idea is
looking at rules for radicals and just
disseminating it and calling it out
they've been spending decades taking
each of our institutions one at a time
it's been a slow march into overtaking
our country unfortunately people have
been sleep out the wheel including
republicans
um not paying attention okay and over
decades of time i knew sports were
coming
four years ago i knew the sport they're
gonna go up to sports and faiths and
they've done that right so they have all
of this media control so they think they
can just say whatever they want to say
any lie they want to make up like
the european virus um or that democrats
we care about you or not racist
everything they say is the opposite of
the truth but because they own the media
these people are believing it and that's
what they that's what they're banking on
is that they now that they cross control
the school the education sports media
you know the shaming you for being
racist constantly
that it's going to work but my attitude
as a gay man is i've been in the damn
i've been in the gay closet
and then i was shoved into the
conservative closet because you're not
allowed to be getting conservative
i got in that closet with threats over
you know death threats and
threats of violence and losing more than
half my gay friends instantly
um and now everybody's in the american
closet and i see it
and i'm like out don't be shoved and
don't be silenced because you know what
gays would never have their rights if
they were silenced so
we need to get out of the american
closet and and shame on people that say
well
i'm for trump but i can't say it you
know what be a man or be a strong be a
woman be
be strong and stand up for america and
stop hiding
be loud bold and proud the gays do it
all day long so why don't americans do
it i'm more proud of being an american
by a mile that i am not being gay
engaged is something that i am it
doesn't what i'm proud of being an
american because it's my nationality
that's actually what i talked about
earlier on the show i don't know if you
were watching but
the speech last night with obama i've
always asked myself does this speech
make me feel proud because all the trump
speech makes me feel
proud to be an american obama's last
night did nothing
he it was like he was shaming us he
didn't want us to feel good about being
an american and i said
you're not going to break us and that's
what they're trying to do with kobed
they're trying to do it with the riots
but they're not going to break us and i
don't understand how the democrats think
that these riots in the liberal cities
are going to help them win
any type of election no i well
it in my opinion this is and this is
what i've got some inside information on
this about people about the whole
riot situation is that the democrat it
was simple a simple
dumb mistake it's like it's like these
these uh
keystone cops they keep shooting
themselves in the foot so they saw the
black support dropping because god
forbid blacks were getting out of
black americans were doing better
financially after 60 years of lbj's
great society to keep blacks down to
keep getting their votes
that's where it all started and that's
where this is the this is the price
we're paying now
is the whole plan from the democrat
parties keep blacks the family
the father out of the family keep them
depending on government so they keep
voting democrat because not going to
bite the hand that feeds their
feeds them right and because donald
trump
one unexpectedly the economy turned
around black americans are doing better
than ever
they got themselves out of the economic
coal slowly and then democrats were on
red alert wait a minute they're actually
doing better financially
so we have to destroy them again and
keep them down so they keep voting
democrats
so that's the reason why they're doing
it because they want to they thought
they could keep the black vote by
by taking this crisis and using it for
political purposes saul and ski 101
right this is what they've always been
doing
and they they had about five days to
find
a crisis to use because the poll numbers
were dropping joe biden said that dumb
thing about democrats the blacks
and then right away they found that they
found that crisis
and they used it they exploited it and
they said
800 000 police and 43 million black
black americans
this is a no-brainer but now it's
blowing up in their face and these
cities are being
destroyed by their their stupid ideas
and they think that will help them but
people smart people are waking up and 80
of black americans and that are saying i
understand right now are saying they
want more police not less
right black people want
more police not less yes and joe wanted
the suburban women vote too
and he thought he had it until this
happened the suburban women are now
saying hey
we don't want antifa coming in and
attacking our homes while we're trying
to homeschool our kids peacefully in the
middle of the day
we don't want that so now they're going
towards trump
absolutely well it's the new brown
shirts i mean they're they call it
nazis but they're using brown shirt
tactics
because this is a great point i i think
uh victor
david was at victor um
on on fox news he had a great point he
said
he said the reason why they're so loud
and obnoxious and in your face because
their ideas are so unpopular no sane
person would agree with them
so they have to be so aggressive and
that's what the nazi brown shirts did
that's what the communists did in china
before the cultural revolution they're
using extreme tactics
hoping that the silent majority will be
sleeping and so scared
that they won't stand up to them and
that's what they're hoping for so if we
stood out
as proud americans and we're just loud
and proud and in your face
as americans we won't lose so we have to
stand up against them because the loud
minority historically has taken over the
large majority
quite a majority over and over and over
again in history
it's evil with a capital e when they say
blacks are doing too well financially
and they're
they're saying we don't have to be
slaves in democrat state so we're going
to go
create this civil war just like they did
160 years ago when they created a civil
war to end
because they didn't want to lose their
slaves now they don't want to lose their
new slaves
right black americans and gays and
everybody else that because of identity
politics
are guaranteed votes for them and we
have to blow up that identity politics
narrative and when we do
the radical democrat party is over
absolutely
i've hung out with him i talked to him
he's a great guy good friend
i've got your website up here
grand opera usa that's the right one
sorry what is your that's not the right
one
that's my non-profit which i had to pull
back from because of
my race john paul moran.com so oh okay
sorry sorry about that man that's okay
that was my
that's the organization i started but
now i'm running for congress john paul
moran.com
you can see my videos my uh we have a
lot of videos we're doing a lot of
social media
and by the way i will be the first open
gay to enter congress
as a republican in the united states
history fantastic
i'll be the first and i'll be the first
from either party to under congress
to get gay um in in massachusetts
history barney frank was here but he
came out after that doesn't count he
allowed to get in
and then he came out after so i'll be
the first i'll be breaking grounds on
two levels and uh
it's not identity politics it's blowing
up identity politics i'm saying the
opposite
you can be gay or you can be black you
could be anything and you can have a
mind of your own
and vote the way you want you don't have
to be told how to vote like the
democrats say
no i agree 100 and for everybody that's
out there
i think i got it right this time got it
brother there you go
that's me all dressed up you don't see
that too much i love the tie
i like that tie yeah well it's like
stand up for america
don't don't don't hide it absolutely
thank you so much i really appreciate
you coming on and spending some time
thank you for having me thanks and and
thank god god bless and pray and work
and get out of that american closet be
proud every day don't don't hide
awesome buddy take care we'll have you
back on and and give us updates and
thanks
as uh right gets closer and wraps up
thank you so much
thanks see you wow what a great great
interview
i hope you win
so that was his non-profit that he had
to step away from but
uh as you got his website now and he did
mention
and we were going back and forth and we
were talking about uh john q citizen
or those who own small businesses
what's going on with them during these
riots and how do they feel about this
this is the video i might have talked
about before
but this is one that's kind of gone a
little bit viral it's in a town hall
meeting where a business owner
uh takes to the mic to speak to the
congress to the electric
elected officials the mayor uh city
council members things like that so
check this out
zapata um i wasn't going to speak i was
asked to speak here
you know uh sheriff good to see you i'm
telling you guys you know i'm pretty
appalled
at what's going on you know at first we
sat as concerned citizens and we all
want to figure out how to best navigate
our way through this whole covert thing
you know
and uh as as we realized that it's not
quite as dangerous as you thought it'd
be you know i was absolutely apologetic
cowardice you know and as you're sitting
there with your masks on
i don't blame you for wearing masks
because i'd be hiding my face too if i
was you
for what you're doing it's absolutely
horrendous when you're doing these
people i'm a business owner
and uh and i'm telling you our families
are starving you know you guys can sit
here with your jobs you can see
you're gonna get paid you can fall
asleep in your chair like that
gentleman's doing behind his mask right
there
okay uh and i'm telling you right now
that right now we're being peaceful
and you better be happy that we're good
citizens that we're peaceful citizens
but it's not gonna be peaceful much
longer
okay and this isn't a threat i'm not a
criminal i've ever been a criminal but
i'm telling you good citizens are going
to turn to
real concerned and revolutionary
citizens real soon
and nobody else is going to say that i'm
probably the only person that has a boss
say what i'm saying right now
that we're building we're organizing and
we'll work with law enforcement or
without law enforcement
but you won't stop us when time comes
because our families are starving
and if you don't hear the seriousness of
my voice i hope you open your ears
you absolutely listen to what i'm saying
because this is a warning
for what's coming it's not going to be
peaceful much longer it's not going to
be raw rise i'm going to be speeches
it's not going to be
down outside saying the pledge of
allegiance it's not going to be waving
flags
it's going to be real when you see the
things that i've seen
i went to war for this country i've seen
the ugliest dirtiest part of humanity
i've been in combat and i never want to
go back again but i'm telling you what i
will to save this country
if it has to be against our own citizens
it will happen
and there's a million people like me and
you won't stop us
open the county let our citizens do what
they need to do
let owners of businesses do what they
need to do to feed their families
take the masks off quit masking and
muzzling your children
the psychological damage you're doing to
them is horrible i've had
six friends kill themselves since it's
happened veterans who lost their jobs
how do you feel about being complicit
and perpetuating that the greatest folks
haven't perpetuated on the american
people and you're part of it while
they're wearing your mask
in shasta county we're supposed to be
red country up here
not blue control red country up here
thoughts it's all true
i think that if you can open walmart
uh you can vote in public
if you can shop inside walmart you can
go
to a mom and pop store i didn't i i
never understood the logic in march when
they were like we're shutting it down
and then i'm like oh but walmart's still
open
and you know home depot's still open
lowe's is still open
but you're gonna shut down you know
joe's
restaurant and bellies whatever i mean
it's just
it makes no sense to me these stores are
actually less likely to have coped
because they're smaller and they can't
bring in large groups of people
right uh i know for a fact home depot
sales
and somebody might be out there saying
oh but home depot limited the amount of
people they're going in the store
at one particular point in time and they
cut back on store hours but their
sales in year over year up 148 percent
that people were going in it wasn't
and they were loving it big box stores
do not mind
that all these local stores are closed
because they're they're
bringing back their money that they've
wanted
and uh they're loving it so of course
they're not gonna say anything about it
they don't care how long this goes on
because walmart amazon do you know how
much money amazon's making
because everybody's at home through the
roof so of course jeff bezos is going to
be like oh the death rate's so high and
this is terrible
because he's making money over money
over money
then you've got your local stores that
they can't even find it
i know for a fact we tried to buy a
swimming pool and they were like hey
we're all out
we have no swimming pools because the uh
businesses that are making the swimming
pools had to shut down i'm like
why did they have to shut down they're
in a warehouse the same size as walmart
well yeah that's a good point i don't
know it's because they don't
want you to thrive they want us to be
down
yes for because they want us to be mad
at trump they want
this was all to get trump out of office
if you don't think the riots
the closing of the businesses the covet
i mean it's all i'm not a conspiracy
theorist
i'm just saying what has happened is a
perfect storm to try to get trump out of
office
they're using that yeah the fact that
coven
came along was an opera opportunity
oh they like mystic uh ideal
thing to add to their writing
and the fake right remember why we're
writing we're writing because a man
was arrested broke loose started
fighting the cops punched a cop
stole a cop's taser ran away and the cop
had to
neutralize him because he became a
threat to society
so the cop had to shoot him that's why
these rocks
they want you to think that's why the
riots began they want you to think that
that's why
right you know because it isn't these
follow the money these
riots were premeditated and they were
bought and paid for and i will tell you
even before george floyd they were
trying to figure out
how they could get this country angry
they didn't care who they had to exploit
they didn't care who they had to take
down with them they were plotting and
they were planning
and it's just a cherry on top anytime
something happens
they're going to make it bigger than
what it is and like i said before and
i'll say it again
coven 19 joe's running mate this is how
they think they're going to get trump
out because when i watched the dnc last
night and i heard nothing but coven 19
and nothing about how he's making peace
in the middle east
and made me wonder what if china
wouldn't have given us this virus
what would they be saying right now i
don't know they would have come up with
some honestly
right right i got a couple more clips
left i got uh trump
uh being asked about obama coming you
know
coming after him or whatnot so here's
trump responding about
obama and what's going on in the nation
now president obama did not do a good
job and
the reason i'm here is because of
president obama
and joe biden because if they did a good
job i wouldn't be here
and probably if they did a good job i
wouldn't have even run i would have been
very happy
i enjoyed my previous life very much but
they did such a bad job that i stand
before you as president
wow i i've said i would not have run for
president united states if it wasn't how
awful you guys are oh on obama's
watch food stamp recipients soared
millions fell below the poverty line and
did you know that in 2008 when he got
into office
and was elected 63 63 percent of
americans felt like they were middle
class
yeah four years into his term it went
down to 51
it actually went down 51 only felt like
they were middle class brian
yeah yeah oh i lived it i lost my job i
was on unemployment i
we were struggling to get by uh it just
it was no good for me and my family and
i know my friend who has a small
business it was
it was slim pickings for him as well but
um
okay the recovery that happened why
would bill
bill maher have said and some other
democrats have said too we gotta wreck
this economy
or he's gonna get re-elected absolutely
why would they say that
because they already had it in the plan
they were planning it out already
but you want to talk economics about
obama there you go health care with
obama remember when he said
you can keep your plan if you'd like
well that didn't happen premiums went up
co-pays went up it skyrocketed right you
can keep your doctor that was the lie of
the century right
what about foreign
right they were pitching it last night
they were pitching obamacare last
night you can't you can't do that
you can't there's still 27 million
americans without health coverage
because of
obamacare right you can keep your
coverage that's a lie
check this check this one out the
reporter also asked trump
which was supposed to be a gotcha
question so listen carefully
and and see how this turned out at the
cost of the theory
it is this belief that you are secretly
saving the world from this satanic
cult of pedophiles and cannibals does
that sound like something
you are behind well i haven't i
haven't heard that but is that supposed
to be a bad thing or a good thing i mean
you know
if if i can help save the world from
problems i'm
willing to do it i'm willing to put
myself out there and we are
actually we're saving the world from a
radical
left philosophy that will destroy
this country and when this country is
gone
the rest of the world would follow the
rest of the world would follow that's
the importance of this country
best answer ever
is it a bad thing to save this country
from pedophiles
and cannibals and kids don't they i
don't think they're not out there
because that's true and then she
chuckled then she had the audacity to
laugh i'll tell you what
um that was [ __ ] she wanted to get him
on a gotcha question in in the sense of
uh this is sounds so ridiculous right a
conspiracy theory
because she won the headline that said
trump agrees with conspiracy theorists
that's what she wanted but what she got
was cannibal
exactly but what she got was trump is
the superhero trying to save
everyone from sex trafficking right
i just right that's exactly what's going
on
and uh i i know i didn't get to play
this yesterday because we didn't have it
but i have it now
and i kind of want to uh make this last
one and we do and then we'll get back
into last thoughts
uh bill gates if he gives you a vaccine
will you take it
a veteran uh elderly veteran who does
have comorbidities
gary anderson made a personal
uh video that he wanted the world to see
him and his brother got the covid and
this is what he wants
everybody to know about when it comes to
covet
and here's my little bottle of uh there
it is i don't know if y'all
saw that or not um and here's my little
z packet it's called a z pack for
extreme cold erythomycin
anyway there's only like five tablets in
that but they've done your job now
but uh anyway um i
on my i came back home after i got my
prescription filled
and um after the fourth
dose i was fine i could tell my lungs
were clearing back up
you know the fever stopped i've been two
days fever-free now
uh and i want people to know about
hydroxychloroquine
you do not have to be sick i'm
also a disabled vet i in that process i
call the va you know what they told me
they told me that sir when you get to
where you can't breathe
come into the emergency room at the va
and that they also told me
hydroxychloroquine was not a government
approved
treatment for covid19
anyway i'm thinking back at all this and
i'm infuriated
that this hippocratic oaths that these
doctors take
to save lives and they're scared of
losing their license
they're scared of the repercussions if
they prescribe it
and that's what they're supposed to do
um
you're gonna have to go out and find you
a doctor that's got balls enough
to prescribe hydroxychloroquine
you don't have to be sick for 20 days
there's no reason for it
uh you know hydroxychloroquine will take
that away and then
you know you don't you don't you don't
have to die
there's a lot of people out here dying
i've got a brother-in-law went through
the same thing he's just a week
earlier than me on everything and he it
was prescribed to him
and he's doing fine now as well um but
again
um i don't know why the left is
is uh is wanting this to be as bad as it
is
as it is for our country
i know why they don't want trump in
i know why too i will tell you this i
will tell you this i looked on my
medical chart and i forgot that
i had a little bit of an er reaction to
azithra myerson
years ago when i took it for i think a
toothache or something
and i got some hype well i instantly saw
that on
back in like april or may i saw that on
my chart
so i mail i emailed my doctor and said
hey
remove that off my chart i got a couple
hives that was it
because if i'm ever in a situation where
i need it and they see that on my chart
they're not going to give it to me
oh really well right because they think
i have an allergic reaction so if i
would have covid they're going to say
we can't give you you know hcq and the
zephyr
myosin because you said you had a
reaction so instantly she wrote back and
said yeah i removed it if you need hcq
if you ever get this just let me know
you got yeah oh yeah she's totally oh my
god no i'm calling you
yeah i mean you just make sure you know
who your doctor is you
you probably when next time you go get
your checkup just say so hey yeah who
are you voting for and you'll know right
away if you're getting the hcq or not
because again it's it's your right to
try as they always say
um but donald trump signed that sign an
executive order
you have the right to try right you do
and remember there's a lot
this drug's been around for 60 years for
malaria little kids take it
uh you know a lot of other countries are
constantly taking it
um as precautionary even before you go
on like missionary trips sometimes when
you go to missionary trips they'll give
this to you
there's never a problem then so again
you have to you have to do your own
research
look up the medicine read about it
pre-covered
don't read about what don't read about
what they're saying about it now read
about it free coven
and don't take our word don't take our
word we're not doctor right
yeah we don't right we're just that's
what my
that is what my uh studying has showed
me
and remember hcq doesn't know the
difference it doesn't know if you have
coven or if you have malaria
it does what it's supposed to do in the
body yeah anti-inflammatory
bring down the inflammation and that's
how you heal so
last thoughts leah just i'll finish off
with the h the hcq
it's safer than tylenol you know there's
more warning labels on tylenol and i
just
i think that you have to do your
research on it and
it does bother me that we are now making
everything so political to the point
where
we have to be afraid and our doctors are
now taking political sides not all of
them
um but when the whenever we went from
thanking the doctors for doing such a
great job with kovid
and then the democrats are now telling
the doctors that they're all idiots and
they can't talk anymore
we're in a fight for our life and with
the dnc
all they did was talk about the fight
for the soul of this country and when
they say that remember
they want to make it evil they're trying
to kill
still the soul of the country in
trump's speech he talked about how he
was talking to god
you won't hear that in obama's speech no
i'll end with that
and i'll end it with this obama hillary
you can't break us no hell you can't
break us
we're proud to be americans we're going
to vote in person
and you can't break us god bless america
there you go amen
with that these are our patreons folks
we can't do this without you
it does cost a decent amount a fairly
large amount of money
to continue the show running all the
programs in the background the
subscriptions we have to have
all the different tools that we use in
order to get the show out to everybody
and a huge thanks to jason and kathleen
who are our hundred dollar patrons
and leah your thoughts yeah just go to
uh patreon.comwd show from there
you can it's actually customizable so if
you want to do five dollars this month
closer to election you want to do 20
a month you can and like brian was
saying this helps us continue to do the
show
it also helps us with something else
that we have
we have the wayne dupree podcast app
you can go to your app store and you can
download this for your ipad for your
iphone
uh really any other kind of smartphone
that you have and
you can you can actually get your
weather you can get your local traffic
you can read the articles and you can
also watch the show from this app
it's easy to use and again it's free for
you i know a lot of people were asking
do i have to pay for this no
it's because of our patreons that help
us uh pay
pay for this through their donations so
we appreciate that
and there we go we're back okay
and we're back look at this and props to
brian for working the show today you
were the
producer and and the i.t guy you were
everything back
so two thumbs up to you thank you so
much leah i appreciate it uh
just uh it's like riding a bike get back
on and start riding again
anyways thank you folks for being on the
show thanks again for sharing it
uh crush share crush like first time
been on the show come back
uh come back at least three times and
people say after about three times
they're hooked so
that's a good deal and i will leave
everybody
with the obama gate scandal
video that i believe trump had posted i
believe this is from the trump campaign
this is from the trump campaign this
says it all this is what it is this is
who they are
we got to keep trump four more years and
just like
what was it biden said eight more i
don't mind yeah let's go with it
baby trump will not be present highly
critical
biased text messages between senior fbi
officials peter strzok and lisa payne
there will be no
question about the outcome of this
election
and she got ahead of herself this
utterly stunned this campaign
uh head home you should get some sleep
we'll have more to say tomorrow our
constitutional democracy
enshrines the peaceful transfer of power
the peaceful transition of power is one
of the hallmarks
of our democracy we want to do
everything we can to help you succeed
because if you succeed
then the country succeeds these
declassified documents that were just
released
officials in the obama administration
were asking for the identities to be
unmasked of americans
unmasking of aids and staffords of the
incoming president
the basic charge political spying to
disrupt the peaceful transfer of power
unmasking
of american citizens uh it could be a
real problem
why is it that the unmasking of flynn
somehow ended up
in the pages of the washington post i
know nothing about those moves to
investigate michael flynn the vice
president said that yesterday
and then the last name on this list is
joe biden
the obama administration was bitter they
wanted to do everything they could to
undermine the incoming trump
administration really designed to
sabotage
and really uphand the new administration
an outgoing president a vice president
and a washington post columnist and the
fbi setting up an incoming
administration wow
that's a real conspiracy and nobody
wants to talk about it
you